أعلى مبنى تم رفعه بواسطة
يد الإنسان ،
هكذا قال أوقات نيويورك عندما
افتتح مبنى إمباير ستيت في عام 1931. تم
افتتاحه مع بدء الكساد.
كان من الممكن استخدام مبنى الدولة الفارغ
مرة أخرى العام الماضي
عندما ضرب الوباء جيدًا ، وكان هناك
حظر على جميع العمال غير الأساسيين
أه من الدخول إلى مباني المكاتب
بحلول منتصف مارس 2020
إلى حوالي ثلاثة ونصف بالمائة
من
الضربات الشديدة للبوابة الدوارة  في مبانينا التي
كانت لدينا في الفترة السابقة من عام
، فوجئنا بأن المزيد من الأشخاص
لم يقوموا فقط بتسليم عقود الإيجار وإنهائها ،
فلنضع الأمر على هذا
النحو ،
فقد كان هناك الكثير من المفاجآت في مارس
أبريل من عام 2020
لقد كان ما نحب أن نطلق عليه أرض
المحورية ومرونة السيولة المستمرة
في الوضع لمدة تسعة عقود ،
فقد وقف المبنى في وسط
مانهاتن ، وهي سمة مميزة
لميزانية نيويورك  g skyline
إنه مضاد للرصاص
تم الانتهاء من تجديد 165 مليون دولار للتو عندما وصلت السرية
وانخفضت عائدات السياحة إلى الصفر
لكن الملاك تمسكوا
بأعصابهم وبروح أن هذا المبنى قد صمم لأول مرة
وخططوا للمستقبل
الآن لهذا المبنى نفسه
الرائع للسياح  لقد عاد السائحون ،
نعم ، هل أنت مستعد للرفاهية
التي على وشك الوصول بمجرد
انفتاحنا على
أوروبا إلى حد كبير وأولئك الذين يمرون
عبر أوروبا ، سأخبرك بأننا ريتشارد
وسأخبرك بشيء
آخر  لقد تغيرت كثيرًا حقًا عندما
أغلقنا وأغلقنا من
مسيرة أه يوليو هنا في
مبنى إمباير ستيت ، لقد أعدنا التفكير في المرة الأولى التي
قمنا فيها بالفعل بإعادة تطوير 165 مليونًا
من إعادة تطوير
جاذبية المرصد ولكن للمرة الأولى على الإطلاق
ذهبنا إلى  الصفر المطلق وأعدنا بناء
أعمالنا بطريقة مختلفة ، فنحن
في مركز كل ذلك نحن مركز
مدينة نيويورك ، وهناك
إعادة دولية
الإدراك يعيش في قلوب
وعقول الجميع من سن الخامسة والسادسة
إلى التسعين من العمر ، وكيف يحدث
ذلك ، ظهر مبنى إمباير ستيت
في العديد من الأفلام والبرامج التلفزيونية ،
فهو يتحدث عن مفاهيم الآمال
والأحلام التي يأمل الجميع فيها و
الأحلام وهذا لا ينتمي إلى ثقافة واحدة
تم بناؤها من قبل
العديد من الثقافات
وقد لفتت الأنظار
واللحظة الخيالية في
العالم بعد 50 عامًا منذ أن كانت إمبراطورية
الدولة أطول مبنى في العالم ولكن
هذا لا يهم لأنه اليوم
هناك مبانٍ أطول وأكثر ذكاءً وأكثر ذكاءً
ولكن لا
شيء مثل هذا
البحث عن ريتشارد سي إن إن في مبنى إمباير ستيت
في نيويورك